Shall we say grace?
Oh, yeah. Good idea.
Hello? God, it's me, Ted.
One of your weirder creations.
Sorry about what I said today.
Not that your deacons aren't attractive, but
I'm saving my mouth for marriage.
Let us not be so high that we have to call
an ambulance. Amen.
Amen.
Okay. Let there be light.
All my friends know the low rider.
The low rider is a little higher.
Bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah
bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah.
Nah nah nah.
Oh, yeah. Man.
Nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah nah.
I was so f***ing hungry.
I was so hungry too.
It's so weird. You know?
This is like the perfect food for the
perfect night.
Yeah. Like, who invented food?
That guy rocks.
Well, if I knew you guys were gonna get so
gussied up, I would have made something
fancier.
No, mom, this is perfect.
It's a perfect steakum.
The perfect
Steakum. Hmm.
It's right here.
Just. Just feel it.
Ah.
I can feel your love in this ma'.
I'm so happy you love it so much.
Jesus, you guys are acting like it's today's
special at Legal Seafood.
It's fine.
I think it's delicious.
Suze.
Can you guys believe, that, we're just like,
we're sitting here and we're, like, having
an experience and experiencing reality all
at once.
Hey, Susan. Susan, I
just want to say you have found your haircut.
What you think so?
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
You could ride this to 70 and you'd be fine.
Well, I just took a picture of Tipper Gore
into the salon, and I said, now I know it
can't be like that, but try to get it as
close as you can.
And so while, uh.
Tipper Gore should bring in a picture of you.
Stop it.
This night.
Is there a f***ing gas leak or something?
It's funny. I ate all those steakums and I'm
still hungry.
Oh, f***, these are so good.
So good.
And look at the intricate carvings.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's some Illuminati sh*t.
That's what I've
heard like that, if you can decipher what's
on an Oreo, you can know the mind of God.
I heard no two Oreos are alike.
Hey what a great conversation.
I f***ing knew it.
Oh, sh*t.
Hi, Blair.
You guys are stoned.
Look, Blair.
Blair, it's a little more complicated.
You f***ing swore it was just for you.
All right?
Okay. I didn't want to have to resort to
this.
I love you.
See, now you're not mad at me anymore.
And f*** you.
By the way, I've been trying for two weeks
to get Susan to fix that haircut.
Blair, listen, it's my fault.
He tried to say no, and I pressured him.
No, no, no, you're 16, all right?
He's a talking teddy bear.
It's his f***ing fault.
Okay, look, look, look, I think if we all
just take a couple of deep breaths here and
just try to- Fuck.
Ted. Come on.
Where the hell are you?
I just want to talk.
Yeah.
Bullsh*t.
How the hell did you get up there?
Climb the drainpipe.
Okay, well, why don't you come on down here
and we can discuss the situation?
No, cause you're gonna come at me.
I'm not. I promise.
It
wasn't my fault. Oh, my God, your boy.
He's on the roof.
It's all right, Mrs. Fetchko.
I'll call the fire department.
That's really not necessary.
But your son, he's gonna fall.
He's not. Yeah, there's a lot here.
You're not understanding, Mrs.
Fetchko.
For God's sake, you've been listening to the
news. Eisenhower says we all gotta stay
inside. Oh my God.
Ted, get down here.
Okay, I'm not going to talk to you like
this. Yeah, well, tough
shit, I'm gonna live up here from now
on. That's insane.
You're insane.
No I'm not. I'll get Johnny to bring me food
and maybe even soil so I can grow crops
right here in the rain gutter.
And if the weather's temperate by harvest
season, I'll be able to. Oh, f***.